switch sports is wrecking tvs and
bringing back wii sports nightmares plus
an elden ring fan has found a new way to
play
it's starting to feel a lot like 2006
around here because nintendo switch
sports players are reporting the death
of their televisions the killer joy cons
flying out of sweaty hands if you're not
a dinosaur like me you might not
remember how many tv screens were
shattered this same way in the 2000s as
a result of wii sports players losing
their grip on the wiimote and most
likely not wearing the safety strap and
even though joycons pack less of a punch
than those retro controllers feels weird
to call them that they have certainly
proven they can be lethal to surrounding
tech twitch streamer 63 man found this
out the hard way while playing tennis
another twitch streamer northern lion
also launched his joy con at the
television screen while playing switch
sports this past week but luckily his
screen survived so let this video be a
friendly reminder to you
wear
the safety strap all right only you can
prevent tv shatters but in other
controller related news twitter user
rudism has modded the fisher-price laugh
and learn game controller to be a fully
functional xbox controller roodism
recently showed footage of the
controller in action using it to play
eldon ring on pc but fans were quick to
point out the lack of a right thumbstick
to address this rootism programmed the
controller's yellow slider which was
meant to change the modes from music to
numbers to switch the joystick between
left and right the switch also changes
some of the face button inputs changing
the c button from b to start for example
one feature of the original controller
that rootism kept intact is sound
effects a baby like voice will say the
corresponding number shape or color of
whatever button you press so good luck
fighting a boss while the controller is
singing the abcs at you but that's
enough about controllers let's all put
on our suit and ties and talk business
embracer group has announced that it has
acquired crystal dynamics idos montreal
square enix montreal and a catalog of
ips from square enix the 300 million
dollar deal will see ips such as tomb
raider deus ex thief and more than 50
back catalog games added to embracer's
portfolio the deal will see square enix
offload all of its western development
studios to embrace a group which
includes games like the upcoming tomb
raider that is currently in development
at crystal dynamics the purchase is
expected to be completed around the
second quarter of embracer's fiscal year
which is july to september 2022 in a
press statement square enix said that
the deal enables the launch of new
businesses by moving forward with
investments in fields including
blockchain ai and the cloud embracer has
made some massive acquisitions over the
past couple years as it purchased
gearbox entertainment for 1.3 billion
last year 3d realms and several smaller
studios for 313 million in august and
perfect world entertainment but alright
i'm finally going to buy switch sports
today so if you think you want to
challenge me let me know in the comments
and uh i'll throw you a pity win
i'll see you tomorrow